from the very first time i did a run i
was hooked
it's a competition and my family
we're about competition
when you get behind that horse and it
doesn't matter how many years you've
done it you're a little bit worried you
know certain things can happen on that
course that could change your life
forever
the jordan is basically down on 800 foot
track with a horse that's towing you
going over three jumps getting three
sets of rings
the fastest time wins boom boom
boom
sounds relatively easy but when you're
doing 40 miles an hour behind this 1500
pound animal it gets to be really
exciting
skiers can crash horses can crash and
anything can happen
a lot can go wrong in 17 seconds
i'm fourth generation on the ranch
i was on a horse for my first time at 24
hours old
i came back from the hospital and my dad
was on the horse and so i got thrown up
on the horse with my dad and since then
keep on riding you guys ready to run
i've been skiing since i was two years
old
been racing teaching skiing for 20 years
skijoring
is like no other rush you've ever had
it is an adrenaline junkie sport
you really have to work together it's
teamwork but you both got to really know
what you're doing to to succeed we're
ninth in the run order yeah what we need
to do is basically watch every runner
before us there are two different
cultures in this sport you got a bunch
of rednecks or or hicks or ranchers and
you got a bunch of hippies for this
event they get together and they all get
along melding them together is important
to become a full-on team all out all out
kick ass and take names yep
you